is the ethical treatment of animals
a part of regenerative farming
so in the way you do things about campo
that's a huge part
uh is that necessarily part of the life
cycle so like the things that you're
trying to measure
is like uh like the way
like like not damaging the land too much
make sure
that the sort of the land is constantly
healthy and it's producing
and then the grazing process and also
the carbon piece
the the fact that it's like carbon
neutral or something like that
i mean are all of those pieces of the
regenerative farming
or is this an extra part to your vision
that you're thinking about
it's all implicit and regenerative yeah
i call it out
separately because we are certified
humane right which is another layer of
welfare that has to do with density and
a couple other things
but regenerative i mean think about if
you're a cow and you're in a
regenerative operation where
the whole life cycle of the pasture
means that you only eat the top six
inches of the grass
and then when there's whatever a couple
inches left then that feels left dormant
that's a better experience right okay so
just think about it kind of functionally
that way well grazing period is a better
experience right yeah
and that's that's not what's done in i
mean that's the grass-fed
piece that's the other piece with you
know
certified organics amazing there's
you know there's plenty of
certifications that you know fed and
finish is also
great but there are workarounds for
those you can have certified organic
feedlots
you can have grass-fed and finished
which is uh in an animal-fetted grass
seed pellet
those aren't things that we do here
right and regenerative captures that
because if you're it's again anything
you're isolating these very specific
certifications
it doesn't have a holistic approach
regenerative though unfortunately isn't
certified yet
we've gotten usda approval to use that
word based on our carbon sequestration
data
but it's not a regulated term so that's
kind of the mix right now is to figure
out
how to document it and it's not totally
clear what it means like for pigs and
chickens which
are omnivores it's very clear for
ruminants which are animals that
have a rumen that eat grass for
omnivores which is like what we are
they eat primarily grain in farming
operations and that's a little bit
more complex so it's kind of a moving
landscape but
regenerative as a word is the better
definition
of the whole life cycle approach of
letting animals and nature work together
you